spotlight is directed by Tom McCarthy
and stars Michael Keaton Mark Ruffalo
Rachel McAdams and Liev Schreiber it's
the true story of the Boston news
reporters who work for the Boston Globe
who uncovered a very disturbing scandal
happening within the Catholic Church as
well as the law officials who were
trying to cover it up now I'm just going
to leave it at that because I went into
this movie not knowing exactly what it
was about I knew that it was about some
scandal that there was something very
serious going on and that it was a true
story I had no idea the actual plot and
so as the movie played along I was
consistently shocked surprised and
floored by a remarkably well written and
active film this movie truly blew me
away and this movie is very subdued in a
lot of ways they're really holding back
a lot this movie doesn't attempt to make
our news reporters who are uncovering
this very unsavory news story movie
doesn't make it look like heroes movie
makes them look like what they are
reporters who care about their job and
want to give a good story and reporters
who actually do care about justice for
those who are wronged and that's one of
the things I loved about this film this
isn't a film that is filled with Oscar
scenes you know the types of scenes that
if someone's nominated for an Oscar they
play a 10-second snippet of that right
before they announce his name every
single actor in this film is holding
back there's really just one scene where
someone has an outburst of sorts the
rest of the film is exactly how it would
be in real life think about when you
hear bad news do you pick up a chair
throw it against the wall start
screaming no
you generally just sit there and go and
that's how these actors play this movie
throughout this entire film as this case
builds and builds and builds to a point
where you are just amazed that this is a
true story these actors are just sitting
there like man this is not good because
that's what it would be like in real
life if you were on a team of people
trying to make something known and
making it known at just the right time
and having all these legal obstacles in
the way as well spotlight is a film that
is so well acted so well directed and so
well written that as you watch it you
almost don't feel like you're watching a
film you feel like you're watching a
documentary
it's so well told its story that you
truly do feel like these true events are
happening right before your eyes despite
the fact that you know you're looking at
Michael Keaton that guy played Batman
that's Mark Ruffalo and he played Hulk
and that's Liev Schreiber and he was
Sabretooth I'm getting on a tangent here
everyone in my theater I saw it with
there were multiple times where people
just muttered oh my god Michael Keaton
is truly terrific in this film I'm so
glad to see him in another good moving
that Birdman wasn't just a one-off Mark
Ruffalo gives one of the best
performances of his entire career he's
doing something different with his voice
and at first I was like what's that all
about and it really grew on me to where
it just felt so natural it didn't I
wasn't even hearing Mark Ruffalo as I'm
used to hearing him that was just the
way he was and this is a movie that has
actors that are giving such good
performances that they really do
disappear into their characters when you
can say that despite having actors in
this film that are so recognizable
that's high praise spotlight is a
disturbing movie but it's disturbing in
the way that it should be this happened
people dealt with it and here's the
people that brought it to light and this
is why they were doing something good
I'm going to give spotlight and a
definitely check this one out if you
feel you can handle the more true story
and some of the lurid details that are
going on I would suggest checking out
spotlight also I will let you guys know
that my promotion with audible is still
going on if you guys go to audible.com
slash Chris you can get a free audiobook
download of your choice they've recently
had the entire Harry Potter collection
on there as a harry potter fan that was
very cool for me to see I've had a lot
of people email me telling me thank you
because I needed a textbook for school
or I needed to read something for school
and I wasn't able to pick it up because
of you I was able to get the audiobook
audible.com slash Chris free audio book
for you I've been running this promotion
for like two years you can download them
straight to your mp3 player your ipod
your tablet your computer whatever you
want to listen to you can probably put
it on whatever device you have guys
thank you so much and I hope you check
out audible.com slash Chris thank you
very much you guys are the best and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes